it's the most wonderful time of the year  that's right as of today December 22nd  valves annual steam winter sale is in  full swing if you're looking to grab  some of 2015's greatest titles like the  witcher 3 and metal gear solid 5 on your  pc now's the perfect time valve says  there are discounts on thousands of  games and software so there's plenty to  choose from special wintery trading  cards are also available for a limited  time during the sale and for the first  time ever a comic called gingerbread  Jake in North Pole noir is releasing  alongside the sale you can check out a  new page each day we can't possibly  cover every deal happening on Steam so  head over and take a look for yourself  you only have until January fourth  before the sale ends if you're not sure  about a purchase feel free to check out  our thoughts on the game at gamespot.com  i'm tony and my wallets already crying